ten days ago if someone put up a fake
trailer for a friend's move for a
friend's movie yeah
and already it was fake it was already
one person was fooled but if it
almost forty million views right in a
week yeah I know
that's insane yeah well you think about
it forty million times fifteen dollars a
ticket that's up when the hundreds of
thousands of dollars there's a lot of
money
there's a lot of money to be had there
is is there I mean do you guys first of
all when you hear about something like
that you talk to the other friends gang
and say like hey guys let's get together
into a movie see not no not in that
voice
no well Courtney actually is the one who
said you seen that trailer oh my god
like what do we do like nothing that's a
good clip I like that Courtney was
fooled we got to get to this thing let's
go where's it showing
wow how did that go viral yeah yeah you
know autocorrect how'd that go viral
yeah yeah but I knew what she meant yeah
yeah yeah I know I don't I don't I don't
I don't know what to make of it it's
just like sort of these weird clips
right from things that clearly have
nothing to do with friends right right
and it's common every movie but whenever
people see them they get really excited
because the show has just people binge
watch it they continue to watch it and I
don't know if that I mean something
should be done yes I don't know what
they're rebooting everything but yeah I
don't know how does that work good
friends though right right that was
about people in their you know twenties
thirties right well that's not what the
show isn't about people in their 40s 50s
right right and if we have the same
problems than that's just sad
no one said it had to be a comedy
Joey still doesn't understand thanks
[Applause]
you